y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniela blandón daniela
buena noche bienvenida y mientras se
desarrollan las vacunas contra el cob y
19 las farmacéuticas ganan una bolsa así
es es raúl muy buenas noches pues
todavía no hay una vacuna que garantice
un 100% de efectividad contra el kobe de
1990 pero eso no ha frenado la euforia
que hay en el mercado de valores y las
grandes ganadoras son las farmacéuticas
que han visto disparadas sus
cotizaciones en la bolsa analizamos raúl
tres de las compañías que llevan la
delantera y las cifras entre el 11 de
marzo cuando fue declarada la pandemia
de kobe y el día de hoy comenzamos con
moderna su acción hoy vale cuatro veces
más haciendo que su capitalización
bursátil se disparara de 9 mil 300
millones a 38 mil 600 millones de
dólares el caso de facer es más moderado
pero en estos meses él se valorizó en
más de 30 mil millones de dólares y
bayonne tec se triplicó
en un paso de 32 dólares a 104 dólares y
su valor de mercado supera los 25 mil
millones cuando en marzo era de menos de
8 mil millones más allá de la
especulación raúl que es propia del
mercado bursátil ha habido un debate
ético por ejemplo el día que facer
anunció una efectividad del 90 por
ciento en su prospecto de vacuna
subsidio vendió acciones por 5.6
millones de dólares aunque estas
operaciones muchas veces son legales
algunas de ellas terminan siendo
investigadas por las comisiones de
valores por posible uso ilegal de
información privilegiada
dalián a nosotros finalizamos el
informativo con este tema que viene a
continuación le pregunto cuáles son los
puntos clave del proyecto que legaliza
el mercado de marihuana recreativa en
mexico trouble este es un proyecto
histórico que allanaría el camino para
que méxico se convierta en el mercado
legal de marihuana más grande del mundo
y eeuu podría hacer en el futuro uno de
sus potenciales clientes principales si
llegara a exportarse en este país hay
por lo menos 15 estados que aprueban el
consumo el único lúdico de cannabis lo
primero que hay que decir es que todavía
no es ley y falta la aprobación de la
cámara de diputados y la sanción
presidencial pero este no sería problema
dada la mayoría oficialista- en ambas
cámaras el presidente no ha respaldado
públicamente la propuesta pero tampoco
ha dicho que no la ley permitiría que
los usuarios carguen hasta 28 gramos y
que cultiven hasta 8 plantas en su casa
pero si tienen más que eso habrá multas
y si tienen más de 200 gramos ya se
convierte en delito penal también
autorizaría alimentos y derivados
otorgaría licencias para siembra cultivo
y cosecha y garantizaría el consumo
privado sin menores de edad presentes
otro de los hitos es que méxico sería el
tercer país de la región en regular el
consumo lúdico a nivel federal después
de uruguay y canadá y cambiamos de
información daniela porque la empresa
española de medios prisa rechazó una
oferta de compra de qué se trata
mire el empresario velas herrero quien
es propietario de kits de media
estaba dispuesto a quedarse con gran
parte del negocio de medios de
comunicación de la española prisa no se
sabe por cuánto pero medios españoles
hablan de unos 237 millones de dólares
prisa de la matriz de medios en españa y
américa latina como el país cinco días y
emisoras como la cadena hacer los 40 y
las colombianas caracol radio o w radio
el consejo de administración rechazó la
oferta porque cree que sus medios valen
mucho más que ese valor
danielle indicadores wall street en
cerró en rojo
oy resurgieron las dudas sobre un futuro
nuevo paquete de estímulos las bolsas
europeas en cambio subieron animadas por
los avances de la vacuna anti kobe y en
américa latina chile subió en medio de
la emisión del primer bono soberano
sostenible por 2 mil millones de dólares
con ayuda del vídeo y para finalizar que
nos trae como cifra el día
paulo se ha jugado con legó claro por
supuesto bueno entonces le va a gustar
mi cifra del día que son las 549 dólares
con 99 centavos eso costará
el set de construcción más grande de la
historia de la juguetería danesa lego se
trata de un diseño del famoso coliseo de
roma con 9 mil 36 piezas esto es más
grande que el halcón milenario de la
saga star wars que tenía siete mil 541
fichas pero sólo estará disponible a
raúl si lo quiere comprar el 27 de
noviembre a propósito del black friday
hermoso y perfecto también regalo para
navidad daniela muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica y ustedes también gracias por
estar ahí conectado a nuestra pantalla
[Música]